thomas burnett cyl co-author of the new
book chain reaction why the title the
idea is really that race it's a book
about the impact of race rights and
taxes on American politics and the idea
of a chain reaction is how each of these
echoes on each other and builds to a
larger and larger political explosive
kind of tension I think we saw that
tension reach a real height in the 1988
presidential campaign with a Willie
Horton issues the ACO you are the no new
taxes that was really the quintessential
example of the of a her campaign based
on race rights values and taxes when did
you think you had a book here I had
committed to write a book way back in
nineteen eighty six and the premise of
it then was at the Republican Party was
on an insurmountable advance because not
because of these issues but their
control over technology I I it was
convinced seeing the earlier after that
the money and the technology advantages
at the GOP head we're going to be
decisive when races are decided by very
close contest the 86 Senate elections
really disproved the whole theory and my
whole argument went down the tubes then
Along Came really the Chicago elections
where you had the fights with Harold
Washington Richard Daley that the bitter
and I did a lot of work in Chicago and
then the 1988 campaign came and here you
had George Bush 17 percentage points
down in mid-september and by using these
issues of Willie Horton being a mix of
race crime policy the ACLU epitomizing
the whole rights revolution criminal
writes a ACLU has been a leader in that
sense the no new taxes think as a focus
on who's going to pay the tax burden and
who's going to get the tax benefits and
the assault on liberalism Bush referring
to
Harvard Square boutique liberalism that
he was able to transform an election
with those issues I was very impressed
and I during this period spent a lot of
time with lee atwater the manager of
that campaign and he and I became if not
friends a sort of politically were out
working reporter source relationship
that was very productive and I learned a
great deal from where did you spend the
time winning traveling around the
country or at campaign headquarters he
was very active in the South Carolina
primary where he was trying to beat pat
robertson and all the while through he
was trying to develop a conceptual way
to structure a winning presidential
candidacy using george bush who was here
as a patrician republican the guy comes
out of really upper class mean and
Connecticut with tenuous roots in Texas
but really is a comes from the
establishment wing and he was able to
turn this politician into a populists
amo story not necessarily a populist but
to gain the allegiance of the populists
voter that was always the voter that
Atwater saw is the key swing boater and
to sort of watching the go through this
process first in the primaries then in
the general of how to actually structure
a campaign how to take this candidate
would seem to have problem because it
was a lead ISM is a Republican Party
that seen as the party of the elite how
do you overcome that and in fact turn it
in the other direction and turn to
caucus into the elitist and it was a
very impressive process to watch you get
close enough to him that his death
impacted you at all was it a personal
thing close I wrote his obituary for the
paper I think he was a significant
contributor to American politics not in
all healthy ways but it certainly was a
major factor helping to shape it and the
lack of a lee atwater right as george
bush prepares to go into the
1992 campaign is a glaring black and a
real weakness on the Republican side he
is going to be a real problem for the
lack of elite is going to be a problem
for him what did you grow to like about
the atwater and let me just ask to
reverse it same how would you go to not
like to take the second hair first he
has had really no conscience he was a
political mechanic and winning was what
counted but in a certain sense it's like
a lawyer and that's a responsibility of
a lawyer but it is when you're dealing
with the election of a president that's
a dangerous on mission and I think I can
explain later as cause wheel has caused
some problems for Bush now as he appears
for the election what I liked about him
was that he was a very direct said very
explicitly to talk about the southern
redneck the populace vote that that
targeting what he wanted to do his roots
in sort of a middle lower middle class
family in Columbia South Carolina he was
of a whole and unembarrassed about that
whole and most people are it was very
calculating but he was openly
calculating it was a unusual quality and
politicians there that many lee atwater
is available to politicians very few the
one who's coming up now maybe it's on
the Democratic side the scott james
carville who you have yet to see him as
a presidential strategist but he he did
conduct the successful campaign of
Harris Wofford for the Senate in
Pennsylvania and understands much of the
same kind of comes out of the south he
comes out of the other side it comes out
of the Democratic South but he
understands what drives voters how do
you make maintain his for the Democrat
the real problem is maintaining a
biracial coalition but the Republican
the idea is to split the Democrats
biracial coalition and build a sick
solid white alliance of really the
affluent in the working class it's two
different strategies Carville at a at a
statewide level and shown some real
genius we'll see if this 1992 election
is the one where he will emerge as the
as the new genius Wilson but it's way
too early to say that there are a lot of
I would not let's wait go back to lee
atwater and the strategy was there any
doubt in your mind or how would you
characterize the approach to race did
they use eration knowingly to divide the
country to win the election I think this
is where you get into a very touchy this
is what the idea of what the book is in
a sense that race alone is not you
cannot run a campaign in America
appealing to race I only the American
people there was a great deal of a sense
of equity and fairness in America there
are though in racial issues questions
that really go to the heart of what is
America what its fairness should
policies try to make the field 11 level
playing field with ever once at the
beginning of the race starting equally
war should policies attempt to correct
for past discrimination Allah history of
segregation and slavery racial issues
have provoked fundamental conflicts over
what is the meaning of equality what is
the meaning of fairness and these are
unresolved conflicts what Lee understood
was that these are unresolved and how
can you move in with various wedge
issues so Willie Horton is a wedge
dividing issue or a the ACLU and the
whites revolution these are ways to
really provoke feel feelings and
sentiments and and the wedge goes into
the Democratic coalition in that case
you know it's as real genius on this is
not your first book what are the others
the first book I wrote was called this
is the first book in which my wife is a
co-author and a major participant and
major contributor Mary edsel she had she
played very significant roles in my
prior work one of them is a book called
the new politics of inequality written
in the early Reagan years trying to
describe what had led to the to an
administration and a conservative
majority that was able to significantly
change what had been Democratic
redistributionist policies geared
towards helping those at the bottom and
the lower part of the income
distribution to a conservative strategy
helping those really on the top and then
I did a collection of essays called
power and money and I co edited a book
with a colleague Sidney Blumenthal
called the Reagan legacy seven of us
contributed trap chapters is did I
notice that you and Mary Etzel both grew
up in the same town we grew up on the
same street but we never knew each other
at that stage although later she came
back to that same street virtually as a
student at Radcliffe and I was a student
at Boston University and that's where we
actually met but we both been brought up
as children on this very relatively
small little Street but I know unknown
to each other in Cambridge man Cambridge
the center of liberalism in America we
raised the liberal my family was very
liberal and her family was very very
liberal not no question what did your
families do my father was an advertising
executive my mother was a painter and
taught art primarily to children my
wife's father's professor now retired
from Harvard and her mother was a
professor he was professor of German her
mother's professor I mean he was
professor political science she's a
professor of German at Wellesley
i would say that their collective ad a
ratings were in about the 92 93 percent
range when did you and your wife mean
she was at Radcliffe as a junior i think
but year I don't want to date myself I
think 64 65 when did you get married
1965 at 66 and she's not here today but
does she normally write for a living she
writes fiction and she has had a number
of short stories published the Antioch
review another publication called the
North American review and I'm hoping
that these will be put together into a
collection of good stories in the book
you will see how that goes what G steady
at Boston University political science
you go right to the Providence Journal
from there I went directly to the
Providence Journal I almost went to law
school I took a job as a summer job
really at the Providence Journal
expecting to go to law school but I like
the work very much and this didn't stop
was it about journalism gotcha
interesting I had always liked it before
and as I as a college student I was able
to reserve every day that the the old
Herald Tribune and I used to every day
in the subway going to school read The
Herald Tribune with Jimmy Breslin back
then writing for it the whole collection
of really great writers that now have
become very significant people in
something some respects and I just liked
that and the idea that journalism was a
way of looking at what's going on in
society getting an Avenue into it that
was very direct and the pleasure is all
I also like photography when I was an
idea that you could go out to an event
you sit down type out a story and there
the next morning it's in the paper it's
like a certain sense going out taking a
picture taking it back to the laboratory
developing the film printing it
and you see this picture come out and
then as I got more into it the idea that
you could spend time and really work on
a story the whole that whole development
process and it sense could be expanded
and then ultimately books and magazine
pieces in addition to his paperwork
correct me if I'm wrong but it's like
you almost get on the amtrak train and
you rode from Cambridge to Boston down
to Providence and on the Baltimore at
the ball game son and on the Washington
that's correct it's a been a southern
travel are you where you wanted to be at
this point in your life so I wanted to
be at the Washington Post and I wanted
to be a political reporter I was very
lucky because I was really ahead
journalism when I got into it was much
easier to get into I could walk out of
graduating Boston University walked in
into the Providence Journal had a friend
there which help but take a test do some
interviews and it's a I'm on board that
is impossible for kids coming up in the
business now I was able I was ahead of
Watergate which we created this huge
surge of interest in journalism I so I
it's been a very nice field has become
more credible and the work it's being
done it i think is increasingly
interesting and significant and I was
not stuck in this period when it got to
be really brutal the competition is a
google one of my daughter's boyfriend's
has expressed interest in journalism I
don't discourage them but i think it is
much or very kid now to to look at that
as a field to reach the level where i'm
at i'm very lucky that journalism is
like a pyramid it's not like going to
law law firms all over you become a
partner and have a very good comfortable
living with basically tenure for your
life journalism has no tenure and you
move up a increasingly smaller and
smaller pyramid as you move towards the
top and the washington post is close to
that top and i have been very lucky to
be where i am and i get to work with
people like David Broder
Ian Johnson at the New York Times RW
Apple is a very it's a joy for me at
correct me if I'm wrong I remember that
on Sunday recently when your book was
reviewed that it appeared on both the
front page of Washington Post book
review section of the New York Times the
same day it was a hell of a hit I I had
no best feel like and where they both
positive i got i didn't want to seven
unhung ball but my wife and I got very
very positive reviews on the front page
of both the New York Times and
Washington I was simultaneously on one
Sunday and it is hard to replicate after
having put in a lot of work on a book to
get that kind of response who wrote the
reviews professor at both were
professors both political scientists
wanted Rutgers the other guy at the
University of California San Diego I
love them both yes is there anybody
that's walking around and either the
Democratic Party or the public
employment saying I hate this book then
this guy was these two folks were not
fair dues did you know so far the one
hostile significantly hostile treatment
of it has is it again not to be a humble
but it's the only one that's had
generate very favorable reaction and not
just in reviews but also people asking
me to speak to talk to groups and and
various things the one has been in the
Nation magazine where the whole issue of
the most recent nation magazine at the
time we're now talking is about the
subject of race that's co-edited by
Julian Bond the former state legislature
in Georgia a prominent civil rights
leader and a guy named evolve weed is a
professor of the law black professor of
law
and I believe northwestern and they
focus on this book as what they consider
sort of a new orthodoxy among some
liberal a faction of liberalism
criticizing elements of the civil rights
revolution as it occurred in the late
60s 70s and 80s do you don't hear the
Republicans complaining that what your
thesis is you well the Republicans do
they have been they have not asked me to
speak I get much less response there the
book suggests that the Republican Party
has capitalized on issues some of the
issues are legitimate but the Capitol
capitalizing they have done has not been
done with clean hands in some cases and
I think both parties have dirty hands on
issues of race and the idea of how do
you actually try to work out fair and
equitable solutions that all
participants feel recognizes their needs
so there is a strong claims being made
on both all sides of these issues and
Republican Party has basically spotted a
majority side to grab on to but hasn't
followed through the serious and attempt
to resolve some of these problems and I
think that maybe one of the reasons why
bush in the early stages of its
preparation for running for the
presidency has run into some problems
with the David Duke phenomena Pat
Buchanan phenomena and the probably the
way the administration suddenly tried to
overrule really all affirmative action
policy by a little Fiat accompanying the
signing of the civil rights act I think
what's happened is that the Republican
Party has addressed what our real
problems but only dealt with them
rhetorically or in campaigns and not
attempted through substantive
legislation through real serious
consideration to follow through and it's
worked for 20 years I'm not sure
how long it's going to continue to work
for them may have asked you who Dan
Donahue is dan Donahue is a former
democrat is a union carpenter who has in
recent years become active in local
Republican politics he's a good mechanic
running things it's kind of like a shop
foreman as a carpenter but it turns out
he also knows how to put together like a
state Senate campaign then in 1988 I
think he was running the Republican
campaign of a guy named Robert rekha and
you find him was in Chicago and I
Chicago if you want to understand racial
politics one way to do it is to look for
places where the feelings are most
intense and most extreme at Chicago is a
gold mine in that respect and I just
walked into head is this campaign
headquarters and started talking to him
he voiced some very strong feelings huh
let me I think it might be helpful to
our discussion if I read what you put in
what is the opening chapter here because
it kind of sets the tone and this is a
interview that you had with Dan Donahue
in 1988 believe idiot so I said no it
says 88 here this is quoting then dan
Donnie it takes a little bit so
apologize favorite time you could
classify me as a working class Democrat
a card-carrying union member says Dan
Donahue I am NOT a card-carrying
Republican yet we have four or five
generations of welfare mothers and they
Democrats say the answer to that is we
need more program come on it's well and
good we should have compassion for these
people but your compassion goes only so
far I don't mind helping somebody has
got to help themselves got to pull when
you try to pick somebody up they have to
help unfortunately most of the people
who need help in this situation or black
most of the people who are doing the
helping or white we White County cook
county voters are tired of paying for
the
Chicago Housing Authority and / public
housing and public transportation that
we don't see they hate it the school
board levy because they are paying for
black schools that aren't even educating
kids and the money is just going into
the Board of Education and the Teamsters
Union and you use that whole quote day
why'd you use that I think he really
reflects a guy who was caught in an
ambiguous situation I think that he
there are a lot of varied at one level
people are very good mixed it at one
level I think people are very decent and
they do want to help and if they can see
a way that really works I they would
like America to improve they want a
black America to Appu there's also a
deep sense of frustration and I think
this frustration goes what he's talking
about but especially to the welfare
program find that from Mississippi to
Chicago kind of an anger that this is a
program that began in the 30s is an
attempt to provide aid to widowed
suddenly without women with children who
in the depression had no other way to
survive and needed some kind of source
of money but now has become almost a
Institute structure through many
underclass areas providing government
support to a non often non-working
community where legitimacy has become
the overwhelming majority of of
childbirth where unemployment is endemic
where crime is endemic and welfare
dependency is endemic and people find a
very disturbed by this because there is
no way to reach in there if you have a
good impulse it's hard with this kind of
institutional lock the region and try to
help people to pull up in a basic
American supportive kind of way and it's
also government finance at a cost to
taxpayers financing non productive
activity these these are very
aggravating thing policies and ways of
living to
too many voters and especially in cities
that are in trouble Philadelphia has
been in severe trouble for example and
you'll find among voters there and you
find this true in middle-class blacks
holding many very similar views but at
different because they do not like it
when it's been used in what they see is
a racist kind of light but they hold the
same concerns about welfare and the
destructiveness to it even though
welfare is not a major budget item as a
phenomenon it is it seems to be
endorsing values work activities a lack
of pursuit of merit and and commitment
and striving that it's disturbing and
very very angry producing and as I say
it's important jacaro I think the recent
Mississippi governorship race where this
guy cook for dice and virtual unknown
Republican businessman came in and beat
a very seemingly popular Democratic
incumbent who had much more money
welfare it was an issue that the sky for
dyes used very effectively to to attack
Ray Mabus the Democratic governor anyone
I unexpectedly to everybody there are
these there are issues at play here that
are very important and David Duke has
raised these issues but Duke because of
his clear racist background everything
else may be masking substantial
conflicts that are taking place in
America that it should not be dismissed
only as racism there is racism there is
all kinds of other bad feelings between
the races and ethnic groups but there
are also some fundamental conflicts but
that neither party is now addressing is
either party in your opinion care about
the minorities in this country I think
Democrats care to the extent that they
need the minority vote it's essential I
think Republicans care and that they got
a benefit with by capitalizing in the
negative way many times on the problems
of the underclass on welfare dependency
on the emergence of a Jesse Jackson who
was himself a very divisive candidate
and and you'll see Republican literature
where Republican campaigns now using
Jesse images of Jesse Jackson as a way
to attack but I don't think there was a
productive effort but you have in
America is a very interesting phenomenon
where overall if you look for the 1940s
to the present black America has made
great strides that overall the
integration of America has progressed
and it is a success story the size of
the black middle class has grown by
leaps and bounds way faster than the
size of the total black population at
the other end though you have a
underclass that hasn't particularly
grown but the problems have worsened and
they become geographically concentrated
and they are very threatening and the
underclass problems served to reinforce
in the worst possible ways racial
stereotypes the illegitimate see the
crime the unemployment the non-work he's
like the bill moyers TV show where he
interviewed teenage boys who were
fathers of one or more children taking
no responsibility these are the worst
stereotypes that people hold a black
America and they are being reinforced
constantly and by shows that show that
perpetrators of crimes so that you have
with this minority segment of the black
community driving the politics of race
too many respects when in fact the
majority has been quite successful
there's been considerable integration
work forces have changed The Washington
Post newsroom is a different place than
it was 20 years ago as is the the floor
of AT&T GM the corporate America the
workforce of Corporate America has
changed become far more diverse and it
is a great deal of success there but at
the bottom it was there are
our problems and those problems tend to
drive the whole political system how
long you been through Western post since
1981 10 years this year wait when you go
to write a book like this what's your
strategy how do you how did the two of
you work together in this case we
negotiated a long time the I had had
this other idea for the for the book my
wife pressed me hard I'd had a contract
to fulfill write a book push me hard to
keep coming up with ideas I then she had
did a lot of filing and organizing of
clips and putting together material I
and then at a certain point it begins to
gel what what happens as I cover
politics is a reporter and at a certain
point you gotta feeling that there's
something larger taking place at another
point you get a feeling of maybe what it
is and then you say it may be a book
year and this was a process that went on
in exchange really between my wife and
me between work activities my wife
pursuing things it's just that moment
though when you see something may really
be a book did you finish your last word
on this book um it's hard to say roughly
the book was formally published on
october twenty eighth it was about 10 or
11 months prior to that that worry you
that things can change i know i remember
reading you referred to george bush
having a fairly good first two years
when it came to race improving a
situation in the blacks and since you
wrote this a lot of other things have
happened is that and by the way have
they been negative many as it is he back
to where he started when he I think he's
in real flux and does not George Bush it
in this early stages of his preparation
for the 92 campaign they have not really
made a clear decision on how to handle
issues of race and that polarization
I'm it does worry you I think I lucked
out in this book's case the book came
out with the Clarence Thomas nomination
David Duke coming up it was I don't
think it could have been better timed
what's the ingredients that puts a book
like this on the bestseller list which
you what happened there's a lot of
statistics and there are a lot of charts
in here and you know it's in it's not
exactly am wearing crib novel I mean
what what is it but what gets it there I
think it was on the news it hit hit at
the right moment it got these very good
reviews which is part of the luck of the
draw I mean when you get front page
reviews just does not hurt your sales
yeah and I think the country is really
concerned about what's going on in
racial matters and they want the country
wants to explore these this book does I
don't claim to have all the answers by
any stretch of the imagination but it I
think it is a provocative attempt to
explore and detail some of the problems
that are going on and the other thing is
the racial issues just have not been
talked about it is in academia ever
since the Moynihan report came out and I
think 1965 there has been a terror of
touching on a lot of the very sensitive
issues of race crime legitimacy the
liberal reaction at that time was
intense and hostile and it intimidated a
lot of the academic community and the
political community another real problem
is that in the Democratic Party which is
the biracial party and it is an America
the Republican Party essentially is a
white party in the whole the Democratic
Party is a biracial party and depends on
a biracial coalition there are a lot of
conflicts in that coalition but the
early use of racial issues by people
like George Wallace and Richard Nixon
made questions of crime family
disintegration so forth suddenly be
viewed as a racist
would not raise those issues without
being rejected as being racist and the
end result was the party ex ex ex
communicated itself from essential areas
of politics that could not be ducked and
the Republican Party conservatives and
now even David Duke are all entering
into these places largely because they
have not been talked about and I'm
hoping that this book will help engender
more open discussion of what are very
painful to issues and I don't think
these issues incidentally are going to
be the solid until the country does go
through a lot of very difficult pain
black and white talking to each other
saying things that going to hurt on both
sides and finding out the degree of
anger and bitterness and pain that's
there if a Democrat in politics reads
this book is the solution there as to
how to turn it around in the
presidential race the book does not
propose solutions the book is an
exposition really of the problem
reporter and I'm not a program
programmatic not a person I think if
there is one thing that the book points
to it is that these issues have to be
put on the table the the Democratic
Party has had a consistent avoidance of
discussing issues of Republican Party
has a tad a tendency to capitalize and
manipulate issues as opposed to go Adam
head-on I think that the 1991 Civil
Rights Act could have been used for a
substantial debate over what is the
nature of civil rights policy out what
does the country need to do can there be
a consensus reached all the way from Ron
Dellums on the left to a bill Lipinski
on the right these are two congressmen
sort of reflect a range of views and let
them go head-to-head at each other or
their representatives or where the
people that speak and fight over
affirmative action these are very if
you're going to have affirmative action
policies they ought to be openly
discussed and openly dealt with or maybe
we shouldn't have them
the the issue of crime issue of the
interlocking of taxes and raise the
degree to which blacks have used
government lately far more than whites
as a vehicle to enter the middle class
these are all questions that ought to be
out on the table recognized and known
and not be sitting there aggravating
people encouraging the sort of private
development of stereotypes so and so
getting away with this while I'm getting
screwed or whatever it has to be more
ahead on dealing with these things I
think that blacks and whites are in fact
capable doing this much more so than
people realize you've done a lot of
knocking on doors in Tennessee and what
the eighty seven governors race or 86
government all kinds of places I it's a
thing I really owed to Dave Broder my
political colleague at the post who
believes in this going around two areas
what I tried to do in 87 and 88 that
worked well for the book was to go to
areas that were swing vote areas macomb
county in detroit southwest and
northwest chicago parma near cleveland
cap county cobb county Gwen Teton County
places where voters sometimes they're
voting locally Democratic National
Republican where they had been solid
Democrats with it these are the
transition areas and to find out what
was going on and race was often a mega
factor these girls are knock on the door
knock on doors are called a community
meetings another very productive thing
is I think he said there are people are
very active school fights fights got a
crime outbreak and then a community will
meet now call the police and to talk to
them and when do you find people the
most honest with you though willing to
tell you exactly what they think I am
amazed that the degree
ivana still you find I just head on if
you ask people head on and you tell them
you show interest in what they want to
tell you they will tell you things that
you would be very surprised and I think
the press has been very reluctant to do
this people are outspoken and I would
say this is also true of blacks both
sides have very strong views and I think
anyone who's prepared to walk go down to
the area around Midway Airport in
Chicago which is south west chicago and
literally walk door to door anywhere in
that section this is bill the penske
district which parties him he's a
Democrat a conservative Democrat sort of
a working-class New Deal tradition
Democrat but conservative on racial
issues I think you will find talking to
people there you'll find cops they will
say all kinds of things except that
someone will be terrible using worst
epithets about blacks and Hispanics and
even some of the whites but at the same
time they will talk about a black
colleague they work with as being a guy
who's a hell of a stand-up guy and saved
their life there's a real tension and
ambiguity out there that it's a no way
it's marvelous to say I think what the
country is in a state of flux and
there's a mixture of decency and anger
floating about from your knowledge is
there any other country in the world
that has this kind of mixture of people
to attempt to either get along or
attempt to divide based on politics it's
going on all through Europe but that's a
different situation it's much more
involved with immigration of not an
expert I'm not but that is read about it
but it the rise of third Wing third
party right wing parties has been
intensifying in Europe and a lot of it
has to do with the integration of
immigrants especially from Africa or
other turkey third world third-world ish
kind of countries coming in threatening
jobs you get in East Germany you have a
whole work for
Chris it's been very poorly trained
under communism for 40 years now facing
the West German workforce which is much
better equipped to deal with the
competitive forces of capitalism so
they're threatened from top and the
bottom there are people willing to work
for most nothing from coming up out of
Africa turkey in other areas and they
are pushing and getting skin head
movements in effect you're getting Nazi
sympathizers emerging a thing in Europe
is you have a tradition they are not a
two-party debate but you have multiple
parties in many cases and that makes it
even tougher at you because a third
party can develop much easier the
politicians you've seen on both sides
including those it would be a
conservative and take positions on race
or take a position on issues that affect
the races who do you find to be the most
sincere in your views that you trust as
believing say for instance their
conservative policies will help both the
blacks and whites or their liberal
policies will help both the blacks and
whites I think a group that is and they
have the hardest time winning the
presidency or a nomination Southern
Democrats are often guys who worked
through they have very large black
constituencies they've worked through
the history of segregation to some
extent and they've gone and they've
spent a lot of times in black churches
and campaigning that some of them are
very they're fairly decent guys London
Johnson a believer I think he became a
real believer he came out of a
segregationist background or Bart but I
think that he his commitment to civil
rights was a fairly awesome thing was
you've got to know Lee Atwater as we
start off talking very well before he
died was he a racist no I would not say
it was a risk I think was a manipulator
of campaigns and he was prepared to use
he was prepared to build coalitions that
would include
asus himself I would call a lowercase
Democrat certain extent but he was a
calculating guy who was not limited by
moral construction you think did you
ever get any evidence that lee atwater
and other Republicans including the
president would sit around and say we're
going to split this race thing right
down the middle and we're going to
become the party of the whites and we're
going to leave the lex and the other
camp and they actively went after it Lee
was very explicitly Lee wrote a memo to
the 1983 to the Reagan campaign I was
comparing the 1964 campaign on the
Southern Strategy at that time he was in
charge of the South said basically in
the South you have three constituencies
you have the Bourbons really are the
absolute Country Club they're not really
that rich but sort of the middle middle
upper middle class voter they are now
becoming close to reliably Republican
and presidential politics at the other
end you have blacks they and they are
reliably Democratic in the middle you
have the southern redneck the southern
populist the white the guy works in the
textile factory he may have come off the
farm often Scotch background Protestant
they are the swing voter if we subdue
the way he would phrase it if we can
construct what he would call a social
issues campaign which often meant issues
that sort of meshed social issues and
racial issues and we can have those be
the defining issues of the campaign we
get a majority that those guys come with
us that is inherently a white majority
and it kisses off the black boat the
Democrats conversely if they can start
to find in the campaign in economic
terms especially the affluent making out
the well-to-do making out at the expense
of the middle and lower-middle class
then the southern populace goes in
it's with the blacks to vote Democratic
that just was sort of realpolitik wasn't
as if he just saw the real politics of
the south is either you have
fundamentally a white coat Republican
coalition or you have a bi-racial
Democratic coalition if its viewers to
some extent on racism at beers also on
the reality of politics in the South it
it's complex racism of that is a very
dangerous word to use sometimes in these
situations because it limits you very
much you've written off a whole class of
people that may have very ambiguous or
complex feelings and also do not like to
be dismissed as racists if you're
involved in actual political strategy
and trying to win an election to use the
word racist is is self-defeating as you
people are divided in American people
have a lot of conflicting forces and
what you want to do if you don't want to
be able to their race aside you want to
appeal to their decent side and build it
and let that grow and honor them those
and their concerns and their their
growth I don't think either side Willie
does that it's a problem right now in an
unhealthy political system and there are
people caught in this middle terrain who
are very angry and I think the danger
for Bush may be that this anger they
have they have been toyed with and not
had their concerns dealt with what are
you going to do during this 92 campaign
I hope to spend a lot of time in places
I don't like so much myself I can do
this but sup to my editors I tell me
what to do I like to go to places as
opposed to being with a candidate where
you can get a feel for what is taking
place over time with the universe like
more I liked I spent a lot of time in
the last election which was not the
presidential in North Carolina with the
Helms Gant race and getting a field not
only for them but also for North
Carolina ins who
what happens in a race like that in a
statement I as I say I spent a lot of
time in Chicago during the 1988
presidential race and seeing what
happens to Chicagoans and where de caca
started in Chicago Way ahead and then
saw that a road with time watch how does
it actually work with people and with
voters if George Bush were reelected in
92 and he had no more elections in his
way what do you think he'd do then about
race I think he would switch back to
being a much more moderate person I
think that he comes from very moderate a
noblesse oblige tradition and you know
he said done this thing was always given
to the net the united negro college fund
he comes out of a wing of the Republican
Party that I think he I I don't know his
own personal motivation but the use of
racial issues by him I think may make
him somewhat comfortable and I think a
second term where he was not trying to
win reelection might be marked by a far
more moderate and accommodating effort
to build up a restore republican kinetic
credibility within the black community
write a lot about the new suburbs
suburbs in orange county and around
chicago and all over the country being
self-contained units almost entirely
white is there any way a democrat can be
a strong civil rights advocate ever get
elected to the presidency again well i
think it depends on how you define civil
rights advocate i think a democrat can
be a very strong advocate of equal
opportunity and a fair playing field
that's I think those are now accepted
principles and American politics and the
Republican Party recognizes that and has
included those principles in their
platform the real issue comes is being a
civil rights advocate does that require
you to be an opponent of preferences
where there is an advantage given one
way or another because of race or
ethnicity that becomes very divisive and
that it's very hard to sustain as a
candidate because you have majority
majority as opposed to you and that can
become a central issue to you that's
going to you can have trouble winning
the memory and this the principle of
preference racial preferences quotas if
you want to call it that or very goals
and timetables in affirmative action
that's promised on the history of
segregation and slavery for 200 years
plus prior to really 19 the 1960s this
country is losing its memory of that
whole time period and the whole sense
that those kind of policies can be
justified because of that history and
there's a lot of strong case to be made
for that but that politically it is
tougher and tougher to do is this book
sold more than the rest that you've
written yes so far i believe it's done
about three or four times better why did
you pick Norton as your publisher that
they have always been my publisher
there's a guy there Don Lamb who has
been my editor from the word go they let
me write what I want to write they could
give me more money but they they don't
interfere with what I want to do and try
to make something into it impose their
own notion of what the market is or what
the it's one of the few small publishing
houses left that's independently owned
the fact it's owned by the employees
although some employees own a lot more
than other employees but it has an it's
got a personal kind of commitment that
is very pleasant to work for if you
learn something in the way you've gone
about publicizing this book or will you
wrote it that you'll use next time that
you didn't use in your other books it's
effective in getting people's attention
yeah I hit I mean I must I'm basically a
reporter unfairly reticent and not a
public speaker or whatever but the more
you shoot your mouth off the more
aggressive you are
better off you are and you want to get
on the shows like this or whatever
television to get I call up people now
call up a friend at the Boston Globe
when's the focus action and said look I
really want to get some PR he says what
we've got a whole year when I do an
interview with you this is kind of
behavior that is not in character with
the kind of medicine reporter that I am
but that's what you got to do to push a
book you got it I've been on more talk
shows radio talk shows I know how to
count and you just your push it's a got
[ __ ] what's what have you learned
about being on shows but what's the
experience like now you've done a lot of
call-in shows with us here but our
questions good that you get from the
audience out there I think very a lot
although I've learned basically unbreak
on talk radio shows you have to to
formats one is sort of the NPR kind of
format which is often an FM station with
a literate audience and more liberal
audience and then on AM radio not always
but you tend to get less literate more
conservative more angry callers they're
both interesting I like to know what I'm
getting into before I get blindsided
suddenly something that's it can be left
or right getting it can be tough unless
you know where you're going but that
that process is it's very interesting
that the real stuff I think and this so
I hope in time is that books really sell
is when they start becoming part of the
debate that when colonists referred them
and then there's an echo effect on some
of me dispute it and it becomes an
argument then people reading this say I
ought to really get the book to find out
what is this
what what's at stake here I think also
and I hope that I mean that the people
wanted that people that are very curious
about these issues and instead of this
being as again a quiet holding back
reporter engaging these issues and
telling people what i think and my wife
doing the same thing on the back of the
book there's a large block it says chain
reaction is a compelling and brutally
frank exposition of contemporary
american politics it may be the best
account ever written on why the
democrats no longer dominate american
politician why the republicans now are
the nation's presidential party and it's
signed here by judy Woodruff was that
your idea or was it the publishers idea
and whoever made the decision why Judy
would um she is on the macneil/lehrer
show it she's very having made that
comment she's clearly a genius no I I
like her and was a very I sent the book
out to a number of people and I thought
her comment was the most incisive and
thoughtful and I did that and then the
publishers liked it and they put it on
the back of the book and judy was very
generous and saying that we only have a
few moments left and this may sound like
a strange question but how different
would this interview have been had your
wife Mary been here I know she couldn't
make it because she had a family
situation that she had tend to but what
kind of person is she how does she fit
in almost her I mean I would say that
her politics are more liberal than mine
that this was one of the tensions and
writing the book I'm not a conservative
but my views have been going through a
lot of transition and thinking she is
more liberal and more sensitive to the a
lot of concerns and people
that one ought to be sensitive to I am
less so and I'm a little more brutal i
would say in a little archer and if you
both been here together you would have
seen some of this tension or whatever
you want to call it or divergence of you
that that can be very productive it can
also be very Russell in America cause a
lot of difficulties and be a stream
working these things to you have another
book ready to write not really ready to
write and I hope in this next campaign
get a better feel I think there's as in
very rough ideas but it's a I'm not
really prepared to to give an outline I
wish I could here's what the book looks
like it's called chain reaction the
impact of race rights and taxes on
American politics the authors Thomas
burn Etzel and his wife Mary D Etzel
thank you very much for going thank you
very much for a pleasure